hey guys it is Friday the best day of
the working week and we're here they
completely unscripted Geo's news to have
a chat about some of the biggest things
happened in gaming this week what was
that noise
Donna Ness could make work good oh this
is our userscript
[Music]
loot boxes microtransactions games as a
service those are the buzzwords of 2017
when it used to be stuff like visceral
immersive and there's been more talk
this week about games as a service
obviously companies like take-two i've
said that they're looking at games as a
service because 42 percent of their
revenue last year came from micro
transactions which is a chunk of change
yeah
recently pretty good games came out with
a video that speculated whether or not
Sarah Projekt RED was going to release
cyberpunk 2077 as a games as a service
game so obviously so hunk 2077 is being
made by said approached red who have
been known for being super outspoken on
stuff like how much they don't like DRM
they have an entire platform good old
games that supports DRM free gaming it
have been very outspoken on that point
and it seems that this whole games as a
service model overtaking the industry is
no different the tweet they replied with
says worry nots when thinking cyberpunk
2077 think nothing less than the witcher
3 huge single-player open-world story
driven RPG they added no hidden catch
you get just what you pay for no
[ __ ] just honest gaming like with
Wild Hunt we leave greed to others
yeah so dad clearly haven't made that
pretty I guess that's good news because
there is the worry the daddy's was gonna
start happening with lots of food
releases speaking of games the service
one of the games is a service that Dan
in particular is a huge panel so I guess
sometimes it does work is a Rainbow six
siege and they've come out with all of
this new content canister they have it's
the end of year two Rainbow six siege is
content and coming up operation wide
noise which is taking a Rainbow six
siege to South Korea and Seoul so the
new map is called mock milk tower
and it's set in Seoul and as part of
Operation white noise you're getting
three new operators you're getting
Jacobi who can hack cameras and
opponents phones there's a fear who
fires concussion grenades and impact
grenade at range allowing her to play a
key support role and then there's vigil
who has an ability that makes them
invisible to drones and cameras that
means the year two of content remember
succeed is a demand but Ubisoft is gonna
keep supporting realistic stage through
2018 and it announced that season three
and what to expect for that the first
round of DLC is gonna be based around
biohazard operators from France and
Russia and it's also gonna be a new
limited time co-op mode and then the
second season will be set in Italy with
two new operators in a map season three
is gonna see new characters one from
Scotland Yard and one from the USS Delta
Force and it will also see a complete
reworking of an existing map with new
artwork and new level design it won't
change the map significantly it's just
gonna give it a little bit more life as
what is what Ubisoft is and closing that
next year in season four Rainbow six
siege is going to go to Morocco with two
new operators and a new map so they're
changing how it's working in season
three you're gonna get all the maps for
free as usual the operators still cost
money in the season past the $40 season
pass and all the new mode as well is
free for all all owners of Rainbow six
siege so you can also pick up Rainbow
six siege right now in the Black Friday
sales for like seven bucks on Steam
sweet and add a whole bunch of stores in
the US so yeah check it out if you
haven't it's been maybe a week I've only
been a week I'm gonna say like three
days since I've heard about blue boxes
yes it's been a whole three days since
you've heard of El Lobo tell me all
about them what's what the latest update
on this whole loot book scenario it's
getting some traction all across the
world it's interesting because it
definitely started at a grassroots can
Payne we're just like in your
individuals your plays a battlefront and
all that we're getting upset and now the
stories about loot boxes are very much
about what's happening at a government
level just locally here in Australia a
university student got in touch with the
Victorian Government and gambling
Commission who said that they do think
that loot boxes are gambling obviously
off the record but the problem is
regulating it because they said that the
laws aren't up to handling technology
like that like they the classifications
of gambling don't make sense to what
digital loot boxes and digital store
fronts like what battle for and half
right now it's not at that point yet
but I think everyone has expressed an
interest in seeing legislation catch up
to where loot boxes are right now so so
a more effective legislation can be made
there was a report earlier this week
that Belgium had officially ruled that
loot boxes work gambling that proved to
be untrue although it's more complicated
than it just being false so what
happened was the chairman of the
gambling Commission in the House and
Chen Marique said no clusion has been
reached yet in the investigation which
is into loot boxes in Battlefront 2 and
overwatch specifically and only an
informative note on the problem of money
and online gambling has been drawn up so
there's been no final decision at all
that said Belgium Justice Minister Cohen
Games has said very publicly during a TV
interview on his website and on Twitter
that he wants loot boxes banned right so
that's kind of where the
misinterpretation came through for those
who thought that Belgium had indeed been
loot boxes well Belgium isn't the only
place we've seen outspoken government
officials coming out on the public
record about loot boxes recently a
Hawaiian state representative came out
and said that he thinks loot boxes are
in fact gambling he likened battlefront
to to Star Wars themed online casino and
once you introduce legislation to
protect kids and everyone from these
predatory online practices and then he
- star wars battlefront - so poetically
ass it's a trap on purpose he's 100% on
purpose because he looks down the camera
when he says he knows what he said well
that sounds very similar to the
Victorian Commission for gambling and
liquor regulation which is the
conglomerate said unfortunately where
the complexity arises is in jurisdiction
and up how is to investigate
legislations has not moved as quick as
the technology at both state and federal
level we're not necessarily equipped to
determine the legality of these
practices in lured the fact that the
entities responsible are overseas
yeah there's obviously a lot of ground
still to cover we need to wait and hear
rulings from different government bodies
see if the ASR be end up revisiting
their ruling that loot boxes aren't
gambling as we do go with these stories
and figure out what everyone else is
thinking do let us know what you think
down in that comment section we'd love
to chat you about it and yeah boxes
they're gonna be in games one used for a
while okay that is everything we've got
for you guys this week thank you so much
for joining us as always do leave us
your thoughts and feelings in that
comment box and we'll be back next week
so have yourselves a great weekend play
some games we're gonna played in what am
I gonna place weekend I don't know Mario
I'm out I just got 500 stars and up to
that super hard last level when it's
become an arrow what about you if
anything I'm gonna play divinity um I
just got to the very first island which
I'm assured is still very much a
prologue and I'm three hours in that's
gonna be the rest of my life alone so
that and talking about loot boxes
forever
oh look forward to excellent good boy hi
you